[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à tous ravis de vous
retrouver c'est ça vous regarde en
direct avec à la une ce soir leur
confinement qui se poursuit au moins
jusqu'au 1er décembre pas question de
relâcher la bride vient de déclarer jean
castex les commerçants au bord de la
faillite sont évidemment en colère
ulcéré aussi de voir bondir l'activité
d'amazon alors que doivent rester fermés
ils réclament l'interdiction du black
friday prévue le 27 novembre prochain de
quoi s'agit-il peuvent-ils obtenir gain
de cause que dit la loi anti gaspillage
sur le sujet on en parle dans un instant
dans notre grand débat on parlera aussi
de la démocratie confiné en ces temps de
crise sanitaire jean louis debré doit
remettre son rapport sur un éventuel
report des élections régionales d'ici la
fin de la semaine et si l'on passait
enfin au vote par correspondance les
américains le font pourquoi pas nous
à tafas à suivre sur ce plateau enfin
nous rejoindrons notre correspondant aux
états unis à washington précisément
alors que donald trump n'a toujours pas
reconnu sa défaite
richard wehrli nous dira comment se
passe cette transition pour le moins
chaotique entre les deux administrations
voilà donc pour le programme ces partis
afftac sévère pour réagir tout de suite
pas faux débat
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs l'émission masquaient
contraintes sanitaires obligé puis pour
l'exemple également sur lcp merci d'être
fidèle à cette émission c'était attendu
c'est maintenant officiel re confinement
du pays qui se poursuit au moins jusqu'à
la fin du mois nous avons donc décidé ce
matin de maintenir inchangés au moins
pour les 15 prochains jours
les règles du confinement les commerces
fermés au titre du confinement le
restaurant donc encore pour 15 jours
supplémentaires
voilà extraits de la conférence de
presse du premier ministre tout à
l'heure pas de changement dans quinze
jours après le début du confinement leur
est donc toujours au tour de vis et
c'est un drame un véritable drame pour
les commerçants on en débat ce soir avec
vous munir mahjoubi bonsoir bonsoir et
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes député
en marche de paris ancien secrétaire
d'état au numérique et auteur d'un
rapport remarqué c'était il ya quelques
mois sur amazon et son impact sur
l'emploi en france bienvenue sur ce
plateau francis palombie bonsoir à vous
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
président de la confédération des
commerçants de france votre avis compte
va-t-il être entendu auprès des pouvoirs
publics on va en discuter ce soir et
puis nous sommes par skype ce soir avec
ismaël ould ismaël hood
il est là bonsoir il a la chance
derrière son écran de ne pas d'être
masqué vous êtes entrepreneur dans le
e-commerce confondateur de l'entreprise
wild c'est une start up qui édite des
logiciels pour aider des entreprises à
vendre en ligne vous allez nous raconter
comment vous travaillez pendant cette
crise sanitaire avec les élus avec
mairie notamment en zone rurale jeux pré
sident à noter des spectateurs je remets
mon masque que nous avons évidemment
bien sûr sollicité amazon pour ce débat
est particulièrement frédéric duval son
directeur général france
l'entreprise a décliné l'invitation
enfin bon soir stéphane bonsoir
guillaume avons surtout fait c'est vous
qui ouvrait le bal comme chaque soir et
qui m'accompagne avec votre billet
d'actu si j'ai bien compris tout de
suite on est là si j'ai bien compris ce
soir stéphane les commerçants au bord du
gouffre réclame la suppression du black
friday
si j'ai bien compris à myriam surtout le
black friday fait désormais partie des
traditions françaises
pourtant il ya encore dix ans c'était un
phénomène quasiment inconnu chez nous le
seul moment où on en parlait c'était
parfois au journal télévisé on voyait
les images de bousculades monstrueuse là
comment on voit les supermarchés
américains et on se disait mais sont
complètement dingue ces américains mais
cette frénésie de consommation mais
c'est ridicule
voilà un truc qui n'arrivera jamais
enfants c'est finalement c'est arrivé
chez vous
et ben voilà en 2012 ce sont auchan et
et la fac qui ont été les pionniers et
puis vous savez on a tellement
l'habitude et d'imiter les américains
d'un autre pays bas que le succès
finalement du black friday était assez
fulgurant selon la chambre de commerce
de paris en 2014 y avait 3 % des
commerçants à paris qui nous est le
black friday et cinq ans plus tard c'est
à dire l'an dernier ils étaient 67%
alors évidemment ce qui change la donne
cette année c'est que ce black friday
intervient en plein reconfirme
évidemment c'est ça qui change tout
puisque vous savez le gouvernement il
vient de le confirmer il a décidé
d'interdire la vente des produits non
essentiels à la fois dans les petits
commerces et dans les grandes surfaces
et ça jusqu'au 1er décembre
sauf que le black friday lui c'est le 27
novembre donc il aura lieu avant
évidemment d'où la colère des
fédérations de commerçants nous avons
ici un représentant avec ne suis pas
l'on casse la tête un surpasse qui voit
l'image il imagine bien que tous ses
clients elle risque d'être compliquée
par les plateformes en ligne donc
monsieur palombes y aider les autres
fédérations ont publié une tribune dans
le jdd ce week-end mais on va voir le
titre de cette tribune qui exigeait donc
interdiction
du black friday alors malheureusement
monsieur pas dans big ben avait vu que
dès le lendemain lumineuse d'économie
vous a dit bah qu'est ce que vous voulez
mon pauvre moi je peux pas je peux pas
tout faire en tout cas je ne peux rien
faire pour empêcher le black friday
il a dit ça sur bfm business donc nous
irons chercher à faire des économies
look plutôt que de mettre le sonore qui
coûte très cher on a juste mis une
capture d'écran voyons arrêtez de nous
faire mal s'il vous plaît succès un peu
trash dans ce dossier c'est que l'ancien
secrétaire d'état à l'écologie brune
poirson elle l explique que si si le
black friday est interdit par la loi oui
vous avez vu ça c'était bien c'était
dimanche brune poirson donc elle a
publié un petit tweet sur lesquelles
elle disait enfin le black friday
il est déjà interdit en france grâce à
la loi anti gay ce piège que j'ai fait
voter début d'année bon alors là quand
même
elle exagère un petit peu son rôle est
notamment si elle prétend avoir été
interdite belle frappe parce que quand
on a elle été chez bourdin l'an dernier
qui doit demander mais alors qu'est ce
que vous voulez faire voulait
l'interdire de bugs friday voilà sa
réponse je sois y est favorable à une
interdiction
moi je crois pas à l'écologie qui est
imposé par le haut en tapant sur la tête
des rues je ne crois pas à cette vision
là de l'écologie qu'est une écologie
punitive presque dictatorial ouais à la
maison sa totalité
et puis finalement on n'est pas contre
cette année à la sq il interdit le black
friday ou pas le texte doit alors ce qui
est interdit enfin par la voix ce que la
loi interdit au commerçant en fait c'est
de chercher à faire croire qu'ils
organisent des soldes alors qu'en fait
ils n'organisent que des promotions dont
nous avons mais quelle est la différence
bon à la différence c'est que les soldes
ça correspond à des périodes très
précise c'est très encadré très
surveillée et les commerçants ont le
droit vendre à perte donc de faire
d'énormes rabais dans ces circonstances
tandis que les promotions
ben c'est les petits rats beke
commerçants peuvent faire quand ils
veulent au cours de l'année il n'y a pas
vraiment de contrôle là dessus alors pas
prendre un conte un exemple concret pour
voir comment ça s'est un peu tendance
est bien on écoute donc c'est un exemple
qui était pris dans que choisir en 2018
voyez là c'était sur amazon
il nous disait attention une réduction
de 60% voyez un rasoir qui était vendu
400 euros au départ finalement on vous
le propose pendant black friday à 159
euros
sauf que je veux dire qu'elles sont en
quête il se rend compte qu'en fait se
rasant n'a jamais été vendu 400 euros au
contraire il était vendu 185 euros
c'est pas moins 60% de réduction que
propose amazon c'est juste un petit
rabais de 15% qu'il augmente
artificiellement en inventant un prix de
vente qui n'existaient pas donc en fait
on a vraiment l'impression là que amazon
cherche à nous faire prendre pour des
soldes à -60% un petit rabais de 15% et
donc la question qu'on se pose c'est de
savoir si le black friday finalement ne
tombent pas sous le coup de la loi ne
pourrait pas être interdite au nom de
cette loi est bien très bonne question
on entre dans le vif du sujet et je vais
d'abord me tourner vous me pardonnerez
le législateur de de commencer avec
l'acteur de terrain que vous êtes
francis palombie même si on voit qu'il
ya des tours de passe passe autour de ce
black friday
c'est un affront pour vous pourrir
commerçants que vous représentez qui
puisse se tenir avant avant la possible
réouverture du 1er décembre
oui oh le mot affront je sais même pas
si c'est un affront c'est une déception
parce que ça prouve que l'état ne peut
pas empêcher une concurrence déloyale
dans le cadre de ce confinement et ce
qui m'a le plus interpellé c'est que
devant le directeur d'amazon était sur
une chaîne je sais pas laquelle peu
importe
et il l'expliquait bon il est l abbé
pierre du petit commerce et bruno le
maire est apparu quelques instants il a
dit amazon en ce moment c'est notre
ennemi et deux jours après et bien il
disait il ne faut surtout pas prendre ma
zone comme bouc émissaire
l'émissaire alors c'est pas tout à fait
le même discours amazon s'est simplement
20% du commerçant à l'art dont convenait
pas fauté on va venir on va venir sur
amazon dans un instant mais je voudrais
quand même me tourner vers le débuté que
vous êtes puisque ce black friday qui
tombe en plein recrutement malgré tout
c'est de la concurrence déloyale
elle est manifeste qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire une provoc c'est une provocation
des commerçants le vous avez un tel ton
petit gaspillage là on peut s'en servir
ou par lectra idée c'est de la provoc
black friday par amazon c'est de la
super provoque ce qui est interdit par
la loi
c'est de faire semblant de faire des
soldes alors que
des sols black friday vous avez donné un
exemple c'est très souvent et très
régulièrement et notamment sur amazon de
larnack parce que on fait croire avec
l'effort de sur représentation de la
promotion avec effort de
surreprésentation de l'intérêt financier
cas la personne a acheté ce lot plutôt
que ce lot que ce serait un moment
incroyable exclusif limitée dans le
temps une seule fois alors qu'en fait si
les gens prennent le temps de comparer
le prix d ollars ils verront que c'est
trop sauf qu'il a quand même lieu le 25
novembre
attention le black friday qui serait un
black friday responsable uniquement sur
la partie promo la réalité c'est quoi
c'est que dans le black friday qui
varient vendredi je n'ai pas encore vu
mais 90% des hommes vont être des
petites promo simplement très bien mise
en page qui vont vous donner envie et à
l'intérieur de sa y aura des supers
réduction s'il ya des supers réduction
qui font faire de la vente à perte c'est
à dire qu'ils font des soldes c'est pas
les soldes là on pourra les poursuivre
mais quand on va l'aider non seulement
ça sera trop tard a posteriori ils
auraient elles ont lieu ces soldes vous
n'allez pas poursuivre les consommateurs
derrière chaque année produites chaque
année
chaque année en france la dgccrf elle
poursuit les commerçants qui font défaut
soldes et les grandes surfaces pour dire
si la tribune du jdd pour comme moi vous
savez très bien que je soutiens les
commerçants depuis toujours donc il faut
que je considère qu amazon en impact
négatif sur notre économie
aujourd'hui amazon fait du pmu washing
si vous allez sur la homepage la page
d'accueil de l'amazone il ya écrit pme à
chaque page a écrit made in france à
chaque page sauf qu'en vrai ils vendent
que des produits fabriqués à l'étranger
paient pas leurs impôts en france et en
europe
et il faut croire qu'ils sont les héros
des pme s'est passé en fait on à bruno
le maire qui dit j'ai essayé j'ai essayé
d'aller voir cdiscount allez on va les
nommer les grandes enseignes des grandes
plateformes et amazon certains ont dit
pourquoi pas leur portée après le 1er
décembre le 4 c'est el adha amazon a dit
non c'est amazon qui fait la loi je vous
dis une chose quand j'étais secrétaire
d'état amazon a refusé de signer tous
les protocoles d'engagement consigner
toutes les autres plateformes
cdiscount s'est engagé darty.fr s'est
engagé fnac.com s'est engagée
rakuten s'est engagé tout le monde a
signé respect de la relation avec les
pme respect des délais de paiement
respect des délais de de contestation
réponse et aux consommateurs
ils ont tous signé cette charte
d'engagement le seul qui refusent ces
amazones sur le black friday le seul qui
refuse de s'engager ces amazones
je vais me faire mouche le cas l'avocat
vous l'avez cité d'amazon un instant au
salon pour les invités ils sont pas là
je crois que l'avis de l'assemblée vient
pas il vient que si on l'obligé dans le
cas d'une commission d'enquêté quand il
vient ses paroles sans limite
moi j'avais demandé à ce qu'il soit
poursuivi parce que j'ai considéré qu'il
avait menti dans le cadre de la
commission d' enquête sur la grande
distribution et j'espère bien le faire
reconvoqué à l'assemblée nationale dans
le cas d'une nouvelle commission
denquête pour moi ce monsieur duval état
est un élément perturbateur de notre
économie et je pense surtout que ce
monsieur a très peu de respect pour les
élus et très peu de respect pour les
gouvernements européens et peut-être
pour les pour les commerçants il dit ça
prend trois jours d'ouvrir un compte
amazon et de commencer à vendre ses
produits sur la plateforme il dit c'est
le moment où les français évidemment
font des économies mais aussi pour les
vendeurs les vendeurs tiers qui veulent
écouler leurs stocks les fournisseurs
c'est difficile de les laisser tomber
c'est recevable césar grange s'est pas
recevable parce que d'abord c'est
inadmissible alors par rapport à
interdire d'après ce que j'ai cru
comprendre de par la loi mais messieurs
vous êtes certainement encore plus férus
que moi avant que modérée je viens de
découvrir le sujet le député j'ai retenu
en fait que les pratiques frauduleuses
dans le domaine du commerce et quand
même deux entreprises ce que m'a dit ce
matin l'un des responsables de haut
niveau de que choisir c'est que
l'opération par elle même on peut pas
d'interdire mais la publicité comme vous
l'avez montré tout à l'heure avec
l'exemple ça c'est d'ailleurs delphine
batho avait fait une proposition et ça
s'est joué tout au moins de les jambes
étaient pour pas dire et ils ont accepté
suspendre la publicité jack black friday
rival ferait regretter l'opération
peut-être pas suspendre la publicité wii
sports est ce que j'ai trouvé c'est un
contenu alors je voudrais vous faire
entendre
christelle christelle bon soit vous êtes
en duplex avec nous depuis brignais
c'est une ville près de lyon merci
d'être avec nous cris des larmes d'une
commerçante ce soir vous possédez une
boutique de prêt-à-porter une boutique
de nom c'est ma portée ouais allées du
jeu précise bien que c'est pas une
boutique de prêt-à-porter c'est un
concept store une boutique de créateurs
donc en plus de ça ça une particularité
c'est que je représente
aussi beaucoup beaucoup d'entreprises
françaises de petits créateurs français
et sinon des entreprises qui font du
commerce équitable
donc en plus de ça je suis pas du tout
du tout du tout dans ce créneau là alors
vous aussi vous dire que vous vivez dans
mes traitements sur le terrain parce que
évidemment votre boutique est fermée
d'abord sur le black friday ça vous
écoeure ce black friday en ce moment il
faudrait boycotter le black friday
alors le black friday may toujours au
curé je n'ai jamais pratiqué en ce qui
les concerne
mais jamais j'ai toujours refusé parce
que pour moi c'est de la concurrence
déloyale totalement pour pratiquer du
black friday
il faut pouvoir pratiquer des marges
énormes
aujourd'hui il faut savoir que la
plupart des commerçants et surtout quand
on fait du made in france est d'ailleurs
devenu à la mode mais à l'époque quand
j'ai commencé c'était pas la mode
quand on fait du made in france ont fait
une marge ridicule là on fait une petite
marge qui nous permet à peine de vivre
donc autant vous dire que de faire des
soldes déjà on y perd faire du black
friday un mois avant noël un mois et
demi c'est totalement hallucinant alors
totalement à tout dire ça devrais pas te
perdre est altérée racontez-nous
exactement ce que vous vivez on imagine
que une grande partie de votre chiffre
d'affaires dépend de noël
aujourd'hui comment comment vous vous
débrouillez vous faites un peu de vente
en ligne ou rien du tout alors pour vous
répondre
j'ai toujours fait du réseau social ça
fait sept ans que j'ai ma boutique
c'était une reconversion professionnelle
j'ai toujours été sur les réseaux
sociaux facebook instagram
je publie régulièrement quasiment tous
les jours il se trouve qu'en ce moment
je suis obligé de publier beaucoup plus
plusieurs fois par jour ça prend un
temps de fou j'essaye de faire de la
livraison à domicile
j'essaye de faire du clic en collecte je
fais des envois postaux
je propose aussi si mes permanences clic
en collecte ne conviennent pas aux
personnes de les recevoir sur rendez
vous néanmoins c'est quoi ça va être
c'est du bricolage sais combien c'est du
bricolage et combien par rapport à ce
que vous faites d'habitude
et ce ne sont pas des vaches des
médailles je peux pas le dire parce que
la première semaine j'ai beaucoup d'amis
de de soutien de clientes qui sont venus
me soutenir la première semaine les
semaines qui vont venir mon avis ça va
être beaucoup moins et je pourrais
vraiment le dire à la fin du mois mais
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que novembre et
décembre
ça représente 40 voire 50 % du chiffre
d'affaires annuel
et cette année c'est encore plus
important parce que cette ce chiffre
d'affaires là je pense que tous autant
que nous sommes au niveau des
commerçants
on pensait pouvoir compter sur ce
chiffre d'affaires pour compenser les
pertes 1 du confinement du printemps
donc c'est non seulement le confinement
du printemps mais c'est également tout
le reste de l'année parce que faut pas
croire mais il ya des mois qu'ils sont
vraiment très très parce que vous
traduire des pauses il en en cette fin
d'année
alors bien évidemment ma trésorerie j'ai
toujours réussi à la maintenir contre
vents et marées malgré les vigiles et
jaune malgré des tas de manifestation
malgré la morosité ambiante
j'ai toujours réussi à retomber sur mes
pieds là cette année c'est la première
fois que je dors plus la nuit que je
vraiment j'angoisse mais vraiment
absolument que je bosse 10 à 12 heures
par jour pour essayer de sauver mon
petit commerce mais il faut savoir qu'un
petit commerce
ben voilà on
on travaille comme un chef d'entreprise
quoi qu'il arrive donc on allait même si
pour vous le 1er décembre
si si le monde estime ans poursuit
qu'est ce que vous faites vous rouvrez
coûte que coûte
je lui ai dit j'ai dit sur france inter
hier soir oui le 1er décembre j'ai
prévenu tout le monde je rouvre le 1er
décembre confinement ou pas confinement
tant pis on pourra même imposé une
fermeture administrative
mais quoi qu'il arrive fermeture
administrative ou pas de toute façon si
je ne rouvre pas je mets la clé sous la
porte à la fin du mois de décembre
un intense ballet cristal et dit je ne
suis pas la seule vous avez des
remontées comme ça je rouvrira quoi
qu'il arrive les dessins elle a raison
parce que je défends bien sûr madame le
sait tous les secteurs du petit commerce
indépendant de moins de onze salariés ou
même un peu plus c'est pas le sujet mais
madame a bien expliqué que nous avons
des marges entre 2 et 3 nous les
indépendants alors que les marges de ces
grands groupes et encore plus les grands
du numérique c'est des marges avec des
produits d'extrême orient à 60% à 15 à
12 qu'on vous voulez vous qu'on tienne
le guen colère en passant six mandats de
grande injustice qu on puisse en
imagerie très grande injustice et une
très grande précarité
moi je voulais savoir madame si
aujourd'hui vous avez pu bénéficier des
différents dispositifs du fonds de
solidarité ou est ce que pour quelques
raisons et j'en ai vu dans ma
circonscription vous passer à travers
les mailles du filet parce qu'à des
conditions qui sont pas respectées et
que donc vous pouvez pas touché
jusqu'aux dix mille euros par mois de
compensation plus de 1500 euros par mois
et c'est bon je sors si vous vous aviez
réussi à bénéficier de sa alors votre
question tombe très bien parce que
justement on n'a aucune information à ce
niveau là les 10000 euros nous les fait
miroiter depuis quinze jours
sauf que j'en ai discuté avec des amis
qui sont dans la même situation que moi
on ne sait pas de quelle manière on peut
en bénéficier
il s'avère que moi j'ai dû fermer depuis
le 29 octobre donc fermeture
administrative total les 10000 euros je
ne sais pas sous quelles conditions je
pu en bénéficier et personne ne le sait
parce qu'il n'ya pas un article qui dit
la même chose et j'ai une deuxième chose
à jouer qui est très importante c'est
que 10000 euros ça peut paraître
con mais ça peut paraître très peu aussi
une personne qui fait un chiffre
d'affaires de 5000 euros
elle sera toute contente une personne
qui fait 10 à 14 milles elle va s'en
satisfaire mais une boutique comme la
mienne qui fait 55 m² donc autant d'eau
que c'est une toute petite boutique par
rapport à des boutiques qui font 400
mètres carrés
autant vous dire que 10000 euros ça
représente pas la même chose aujourd'hui
vous ne parliez tout à l'heure de
novembre/décembre novembre décembre ce
sont des périodes où on allait plus gros
stock mois par solidarité lors du
dernier confinement est là aussi j'ai
maintenu mes commandes
si je ne les maintient pas je mets des
tas d'entreprises en péril et des tas de
créateurs en péril
donc j'ai joué la solidarité mais c'est
bien sauf qu'aujourd'hui je me suis
endetté j'ai fait un premier pga je vais
pas en faire un deuxième
je venais de terminer mon emprunt j'ai
été obligé d'en refaire un deuxième
donc je devais pouvoir commencer à me
verser un salaire correct je ne peux
toujours pas à cause de ce qu'on filme
merci beaucoup je les aime ça c'est au
times non non je voudrais terminer à
l'élever l'histoire des dix milles au
leader des 10000 euros
je voudrais juste dire qu'à pour des
personnes quand elles ont cent mille
euros de stocks aujourd'hui à financer
aux deux cent mille euros ce qui n'est
pas mon cas
heureusement dix mille euros c'est une
goutte d'eau dans la mer ça ne suffira
pas donc toutes les aides de l'état
c'est bien là des bonnes intentions mais
je crois qu'ils sont pas du tout en
contact avec la réalité en contact nos
nerfs mais aujourd'hui c'est la faillite
qui menace cliquez là en fait c'est ce
qu'elle nous dit christelle tiré ce soir
est au fond les aides n'y changeront
rien les aides elles changeront
énormément on s il vous plait c'est à
dire que ce qui pose problème
aujourd'hui avec les aides et je les dis
à bruno le maire hier c'est la réalité
du dernier kilomètre
vous avez raison madame ça fait déjà
quinze jours qu'on parle des 10000 euros
mais le dispositif qui va être activable
qu'à partir de la semaine prochaine donc
c'est vrai que si vous chercher sur
internet
moi j'ai cherché sur internet pour
expliquer aux commerçants c'est très dur
parce qu a rien qui expliqué de façon
détaillée
il a expliqué que le meut le pro le
ministre a annoncé que ce serait le cas
donc là maintenant ça devient beaucoup
plus clair vous aurez la capacité pour
tous les mois de fermeture de vous faire
rembourser jusqu'à 10000 euros de tous
les frais fixes que vous avez
et une compensation du chiffre
d'affaires que vous n'avez pas réalisé
sur le sujet que vous disiez tout à
l'heure de vous avez abordé madame et
que j'abordais aussi de ce qui se passe
à travers le filet de la raquette
bon effectivement les entreprises pour
qui dix mille euros c'est pas assez
c'est à dire ce qu'ils faisaient cent
mille euros de chiffre d'affaires par
mois qui a fait des énormes
investissements qui ont réaménagé une
boutique cela aujourd'hui les
dispositifs ne les accompagne pas on va
les aider à gagner dix mille euros on va
mettre leur personnel en chômage partiel
donc au moins les emplois sont protégés
mais investissement lui est détruite
j'aimerais qu'on avance vous dire
ajouter un mot là-dessus francis pas si
j'aurais comparé ensuite avec malouda en
tête vous pourrez lui donner mon
téléphone
on va le faire il y a un numéro unique
mais j'ai demandé aujourd'hui
à l'état la grise et qui connaît quand
même les petites entreprises et ça me
rend s'en félicite et je j'ai proposé
que ce numéro unique comme ça se fait
pour d'autres circonstances parfois des
catastrophes naturelles soit sur toutes
les chaînes de télé et de radio numéro
unique et là le numéro unique permettra
en versant des trop riches salle des
fêtes vers un axe ou un autre en
fonction à la situation
je voudrais qu'on ronde et d'un mode
amazon parce qu'on a bien compris qu'il
au centre du dossier
et puis qu'ensuite on voit avec ismaël
où il n'ya pas des possibilités pour
accompagner les entreprises à vendre en
ligne à mettre en place des plateformes
notamment dans les zones plus éloignées
des centres villes mais d'abord
évidemment on l'a compris qui dit black
friday dit amazon
faut-il le diaboliser le boycotter at il
véritablement tirer son épingle du jeu
dans cette crise oui mais avec quelle
ampleur les clés pour comprendre avec
nathalie gloire combien pèse amazon pour
le secrétaire d'état au numérique cédric
au nom amazon n'est pas si important que
ça en france lire actuellement une
psychose française sur amazon qui n'a
pas beaucoup de sens le e-commerce c'est
10% du commerce en france amazon c'est
20% du e-commerce en france y'a pas un
pays européen où amazon et plus bas
qu'en france pour autant le géant
américain est à la tête du top 5 des
sites où les français dépensent le plus
devant ces disques ou une vie plis fnac
ou darty
tout commence en 1994 pour amazon créée
par l'homme d'affaires jeff bezos ce qui
est devenu avec cette plateforme l'homme
le plus riche du monde
au total c'est près d'un français sur
trois qui achètent sur amazon amazon a
t'il réellement profité du premier
confinement étonnamment non selon une
étude du cabinet kantar sur 100 euros
dépensés en ligne par les français 13 le
son sur amazon le géant américain a
perdu 8 points de parts de marché durant
cette période une baisse qui pourrait
s'expliquer par l'interdiction de vendre
des produits d'un essentiel durant cinq
semaines
un recul à relativiser bien sûr car
amazon a triplé ses bénéfices au niveau
mondial au troisième trimestre 2020 pour
atteindre 96 milliards de dollars
faut-il diaboliser amazon pour certains
oui
roselyne bachelot la ministre de la
culture n'hésite pas à appeler au
boycott d'amazon idée reprise par la
maire de paris le dit vraiment aux
parisiennes et aux parisiens
n'achetez pas sur amazon amazon c'est la
mort de nos librairies et de notre vie
de quartier acheter chez votre libraire
certains mais refuse même l'implantation
d'amazon dans leur commune aujourd'hui
dans ce contexte
olivier faur relance l'idée d'une taxe
gaf a je propose qu'il y ait une taxe
exceptionnelle sur les gars fin qui
permettent justement d'aller abonder un
fonds de solidarité en faveur de ceux
qui sont aussi obligés de famille
aujourd'hui mais pour l'instant
l'exécutif et car toute taxe
exceptionnelle on imaginait le
gouvernement n'est pas un peu en deçà de
ce qu'il faudrait faire pour mettre de
la pression sur amazon quand on entend
cédric au dire au fond il faut arrêter
de diaboliser ou bruno le maire dira
c'est le ça n'est pas un bouc émissaire
il ne faut pas en faire un bouc
émissaire
amazon n'est pas la cause de tous nos
maux mais d'un compte amazon se pose un
gros problème
donc c'est ça c'est simple sommes
simplement salle équilibre qu'il faut
avoir moi j'essaie à travers mon rapport
d'apporter un éclairage sur l'impact
d'amazon sur l'emploi je regarde
aujourd'hui l'impact d'amazon sur
l'économie la commission européenne
aujourd'hui regarde l'impact d'amazon
sur l'économie est dit on va les
poursuivre on va mener une enquête de la
commission c'est énorme unique d'être
active d'emploi qui n'encombre à cette
énorme accord et la commission elle va
enquêter sur de quelle manière amazon a
arnaqué les pme qui vendait sur son site
en regardant les comportements des
consommateurs qui achetaient chez séché
ces pme à travers amazon et comment
amazon a fait bon ben je vais regarder
et tout ce qui marche bien je vais faire
moi même
donc en fait ils ont amené des ratages
basse et du piratage complet est donc
maintenant il va y avoir une enquête
européenne sur sa canne et loi mais qui
n'ont pas voté et des propositions à
moratoire sur les entrepôts on arrête de
construire des entrepôts y est même des
élus de terrain qui ne donne pas des des
permis de construire il faut les
soutenir
j'ai fini si je peux m'exprimer un
instant sur le sujet mais là je
grèce à toi et à monsieur le député ça
fait plusieurs mois que j'ai fait une
pétition nous avons fait une tribune
avec des centaines de collectif des
députés
certains députés tout au moins pour que
l'équité en terme d'urbanisme et en
termes de paiement de la tascom
s'applique à aux grands dépôts
numériques ma zone ou autre même des
dépôts français parce que quand on fait
une loi on la fait pas un peu pour les
français un peu pour les internationaux
voient c'est une loi est bien
actuellement
nous ne sommes pas entendus je pense que
ça vient de très très haut niveau de
l'état je ne citerai pas le prix ferme
de la république on n'est pas cité ses
bons et qu'ils pensent et bien on ne
veut pas toucher amazon on ne veut pas
alors que ce serait très facile de
revoir le statut des entrepôts amazon
qui sont considérés aujourd'hui comme un
entrepôt parce que les grandes surfaces
quelles qu'elles soient auront des
entrepôts pour a pris vous a profité
d'un magasin et bien amazon pour
s'installer un permis de construire pour
lequel il est en cachette jusqu'au bout
avait des comptes avant ce match là
derrière amazon ne dit jamais que ces
amazones quand ils sont et s'ils
faisaient par ailleurs cette zone après
il ya une étude de territorialité et une
autorisation du préfet et le dépôt se
créer bon il ya des collectifs via des
luttes il ya des révoltes et la tascom
n'est pas payé quoi la glace comme c'est
un début
quant à scott c'est pas la tâche comme
la taxe sur les mètres carrés de au delà
de 4chan arcari le député va vous
répondre
moner d'attention dans toutes les
grandes surfaces tous les 17 d'un
traitement de faveur ne paye pas ça mais
amazon parce que il est considéré comme
un simple dépôt sais pas mais ce sont
des dépôts de vente et ça me fait un
député être il faut que vous preniez
acte de cela peut-être pour heurter un
peu au plus haut niveau dont vous voyez
que j'ai jamais eu trop peur de ça quand
même
alors ne pense jamais eu trop peur de ça
france et ça non je sais on pourrait
parler on va dire une chose pareille
- qu'est-ce qui se passe amazon il n'y a
pas un traitement de faveur pour amazon
s'est jusqu'à maintenant ne va plus vite
que notre capacité à nous adapter aux
transformations de l'économie ils ont en
théorie c'est un les entreprises n'ont
jamais été des magasins virtuels plus
gros qu'un centre commercial depuis
amazon
il se trouve qu'on a des entrepôts qui
d'habitude étaient des plateforme neutre
c'est-à-dire qu'on vient livrer et
qu'ensuite s'est vendu quelque part et
ce quelque part on le taxe très bien
quand même on tape un peu sur la
pression pour cette majorité traîne un
peu les pieds non non non non non j'y
crois pas je pense que amazon va très
très vite et je pense qu'on va pas assez
vite
ça c'est sûr mais qu'a la zone va très
très très évasive et le mérite que vous
c'est que vous n'êtes pas d'avis que le
monde entier vont plus vite que les
états unis vont plus vite que l'europe
ils vont plus vite que la france donc
maintenant il faut qu'on reste rare et
de taxer les entrepôts amazon ça prend
combien de temps dès lors qu'on est
d'accord mais pascal aller très vite et
moi je crois qu'il faut avancer dans
cette direction pour une raison quand on
installe un nouveau centre commercial
il faut plusieurs mois de consulter
plusieurs des six autorisations
autorités nationales à nouveau gymnase
une date sans rien demain sera fait ce
qu'on veut en tout cas le message est
bien passé
vous êtes d'accord on va voir si il sera
suivi d'effets bonsoir bonsoir ismail
ould j'aimerais vous interroger sur le
débat que nous avons en ce moment avant
de devenir sur vos propositions vous
même vous êtes au fond un peu en
bataille contre amazon est ce que est ce
que au fond c'est un c'est un combat
légitime ou perdue d'avancé pour les
jeunes le débat ce n'est pas bon amazon
ou dire que l'enjeu et le piano ou un
état un cadre qui soit être l'heureux
commercial évolutions ne sont ne sont
pas et ils voulaient juste et comment du
nos petits commerces donne plus de
moyens et nous détestions c'est le plus
beau tableau à la fois pondéré mais nous
on commence justement j'espère que la
connexion du sondes
notre liaison va être va s'améliorer on
va essayer le modifier mais dites nous
comment vous avec votre entreprise vous
aider les commerçants à tirer profit de
la vente en ligne
alors quand j'écris son contenu de leur
combat personnel m'acheter des
commerçants hôteliers ou peut-être autre
formation que connaît le pays maintenant
à savoir l'hôtellerie la tenue à 15 ans
selon lui des personnes
il est aujourd'hui booking en 7 %
quasiment toutes les réservations il
faut comprendre que cet exemple est
important parce que tout ce qui est en
notre connaissent la question c'est
cette paupérisation de nos petits
commerces
est-ce que tout le travail et sous
l'égide amazon est ce que vous l'avez
dit les croiseurs à reprises pour la
mère donc nous comment l'accord en bout
dans ces outils dans les mains des
petits commerces
donc on a développé un modèle dans les
mairies démarquer de pesto talent parce
que aller sur internet de très compliqué
c'est changer son modèle opérationnel de
partir en ligne alors adapter sa
communauté
on essaie d'adapter ce cas patent de
vendre et donc aujourd'hui on a
développé une plateforme qui s'appelle
mon commerce rentre - nous permet aux
mairies en local de mettre à dispo pour
leurs commerçants comment marcher en
paix mais sur internet
la mairie avait de quoi y avait des
services logistiques génie local
territoriales pour voir comment on a
bien compris
malheureusement la connexion n'est pas
excellente
on va essayer de rétablir sa ismaël hood
est ce que ça peut être une solution
francis balle mais on voit que les
français demandent que les commerces de
proximité puissent vendre leurs produits
en ligne comme un gros retard en france
donc pas parler pour de la merde fois
qu'il ya seulement deux tiers des petits
commerces qui nous ne serait ce qu'un
site internet absolument que 2/3 ça fait
vraiment là on a une entreprise qui
propose au fond une logistique
des moyen d'encaissement des moyens
d'approvisionnement des plateformes en
lien avec les mairies qui d'ailleurs
paie une partie du coût pour que les
petits commerces de proximité se
retrouvent ensemble sur des plateformes
pour pouvoir acheter les motive amazon
aller là et mounir tu le sais j'ai un
opérateur qui travaillent et que j'ai
validé qui est acquis a créé une
plateforme qui s'appelle simpl map simpl
maps et une cartographie de tous les
commerçants qui rentre dans le jeu de
cette plateforme mais elle a une
particularité et tu le dois je sais que
tu t'étais pencher sur ce dossier de
stéphane tranchant qui est le
propriétaire le la start-up flaques
d'eau et bien cette cette plateforme
céder sous forme coopérative alors sous
forme coopérative pour les commerçants
elle a été validée d'ailleurs elle va
être validé dans la deuxième tranche de
l'état récemment
eh bien ça veut dire que pour 35 euros
de parts sociales acheter dans la coop
le commerçant est dans la boucle de tous
les outils ont le forme il peut vendre
dessus il peut informer les
collectivités locales peuvent rentrer
également on le on le gratifie ici la d
re est écologique etc
donc ça veut dire qu'on n'a pas besoin
ce qui m'a horrifié quand le pdg
d'amazon a osé s'exprimer et à dire mais
moi ce n'est chez moi bientôt close et
pas que des entreprises se laisse
attirer par dd des gros acteurs comme ça
il faut nous construire et très vite
alain l'aide de l'état mais vous le
faites dans le condroz là on serait très
fort parce qu'une façon de rendre
désirable le e-commerce des commerces de
proximité c'est la complétude de l'offre
honnêtement notre petit libraire locale
s'il est pas en réseau avec tous les
autres libraires de la ville ou avec
d'autres commerces de la ville
ça va être dur de le trouver son site
mais si en tant que parisien si en tant
qu'habitant de villetaneuse
j'ai un site sur lequel je retrouve tous
les commerçants de l'état nous tous et
poissonniers les bouchers les libraires
que toutes enregistrées alors j'aurai un
intérêt personnel à aller sur ce site là
et donc c'est pour ça qu'on les
accompagne financièrement
je prends l'exemple de l'île de france a
requis par habiter en ile de france vous
toucher jusqu'à 20000 euros de la part
de l'est en tant que commune chine que
je suis villetaneuse je mettre en place
cette plate forme de vie
l'état me donne vingt mille la région me
donne 10 mille et si en plus je fais ça
dans la tête d'un projet quartiers
prioritaires ou dans le cadre d'un
projet centre ville alors je peux avoir
un financement complémentaire une offre
comme bwin com
singh pall mall il existe cinq ou six
autres concurrents comme ça aujourd'hui
en france ces quelques dizaines de
millions d'euros à mettre en place et
une ou deux personnes à temps plein pour
faire la tournée des commerçants et leur
fils a pas dix mille ans pour s'inscrire
est pour maintenant c'est pour la ville
c'est la ville qui installe ses la ville
pour que ça coûte quasiment rien aux
commerçants alors il se mêle ou
d'apparemment on a retrouvé une
connexion qui a un petit peu meilleure
puisque c'est vous qui pratiquaient ces
alternatives amazones ces nouvelles
plateformes en lien avec les avec les
mairies on se rend compte que finalement
il ya il ya une demande et donc il ya un
marché pour cela qu'est ce que vous
attendez vous des pouvoirs publics et
des élus qu'on accélère le mouvement
alors je peux dire c'est que les murs
ont été mis en place
donc il ya via la caisse des dépôts la
banque bta corps qui alors qu'il
supporte en de 20000 euros et mairie
nous en tant qu'acteur on s'est adapté à
ce que budget rappelle au maire
qu'aujourd'hui les gratuits de pouvoir
mettre en place une plateforme pour la
mairie et pour les commerçants
donc concrètement c'est un appel aux
maires pour pouvoir contacter des
solutions comme les nôtres pour mettre
en place et marketplace l'hôtel qui
permettent de recenser l'ensemble des
commerçants au niveau local de les
connecter aux acteurs logistiques tels
que la poste pour leur permettre de
réaliser la commande en ligne
aujourd'hui les solutions existent et on
doit les déployer au niveau local
c'est vraiment une ingénierie au niveau
de la commune qui doit se mettre en
place pour permettre aux commerçants de
digitaliser mais il ya un gros retard en
france de ce point de vue il ya un
énorme retard
on a quasiment 50% des commerçants
aujourd'hui qu'ils attendent de passer
au numérique et qui peuvent y passer et
notre objectif nous chez wind tête dans
les trois à six mois en plus les y
amener forcé par l'urgence sanitaire
merci beaucoup on a un petit peu voilà
tu vous entendre de façon un peu plus
distinctes excusez nous pour cette
connexion vous aurez le mot de la fin
c'est vous le permettez à les princesses
ballo bi francis dans ce que je veux
dire aux représenter les gars merci 19e
qui est un drame sur le plan sanitaire
sur le plan sociétal sur le plan
économique pour le numérique je le dis
clairement ça nous a donné un coup de
pied au derrière phénoménale et je peux
vous dire que d'ici un an
il y aura eu deux courses en sera tutu
contribuera à ce genre de choses avec
ton collègue de cédric aux festayres
mais c'est vrai que nous avions pris du
retard mais ce retard on va le rattraper
vous serez vézère black friday un palais
on va on va voir la merci d'un d'autres
moyens que le black friday la fête du
commerce et bien d'autres opérations non
américaine laisse vers l'internet offre
merci merci beaucoup on a appris
beaucoup de choses ce soir bon courage
pour cette période
leur confinement en espérant que vous
allez pouvoir ouvrir d'ici le 1er
décembre merci stéphane merci mounir
majorité beaucoup d'avoir été sur ce
plateau on va ouvrir à présent une
petite page américaine un l'amérique
vous le savez un président élu joe biden
mais toujours pas de reconnaissance
officielle par le vaincu à quoi joue
donald trump
c'est ce qu'on va voir tout de suite
[Musique]
voilà direction washington à présent
pour retrouver notre richard wehrli
nationale bonsoir richard c'est un
plaisir de vous retrouver vous avez
suivi pour votre quotidien suisse le
temps mais pour cette émission également
cette campagne folle haletante et toutes
ses suites rocambolesque d'abord quelle
est l'atmosphère sur place alors écoutez
là je vous parle de washington en
l'occurrence du national press club où
se retrouve la plupart des journalistes
et bien je peux vous dire que quand vous
dénonce descendez dans la rue elles sont
quasiment vides ce qui est très étonnant
on a l'impression d'une capitale
fédérale ont dormi endormi bien
évidemment à cause du coc vide endormi
également à cause de la peur des
violences post électorales
beaucoup de façade sont couvertes de
palissades de bois et enfin endormi
parce que vous l'avez dit il n'y a
toujours pas de transition puisque pour
l'instant donald trump refuse
obstinément de reconnaître ces de sa
défaite est donc de passer le pouvoir à
son successeur
donc ils s'entêtent donald trump à quoi
joue-t-il précisément alors c'est la
grande question que tout le monde se
pose ce qui est certain c'est que son
armée d'avocats
les appels est à la recherche d'un
smoking gun donc cet élément qui ferait
tout déraille et qui prouverait qu'il y
a eu au moins dans un état voire
plusieurs
une fraude destinée à le faire perdre
mais pour l'instant rien de la sorte on
n'a rien vu et maintenant ses avocats ce
qu'il tente de faire c'est de retarder
au maximum la certification des
résultats qui est en train de se faire
parce que vous savez aux états unis le
scrutin il est géré par chaque état
certains ont déjà déposé leurs résultats
définitifs depuis le 5 novembre les
derniers le feront vers le 23 novembre
donc vous voyez que la fenêtre de tir
est très court les avocats de trump sont
engagés dans une course contre la montre
course contre la montre mais guérilla
judiciaire qui se poursuit
comment qualifier cette drôle de
transition entre les deux
administrations
du côté pour l'instant elle est
inexistante d'être cette transition on
pourrait parler d'un dialogue de sourds
puisque d'un côté vous avez une maison
blanche dans laquelle on ne sait pas
exactement ce qui se trame la maison
blanche élite ici à moins de 200 mètres
de l'endroit où je me trouve
il n'y a personne qui rendent personne
qui sort il y à des manifestants mais
pas très nombreux dehors donc on a
l'impression d'une forteresse
présidentiel assiégé et de l'autre vous
avez joe biden qui depuis wilmington son
quartier général du de la r&d en train
de constituer son équipe il vient de
nommer son futur chief of staff
le secrétaire général de la présidence
mais ce qu'il n'a pas encore obtenu ces
les 10 millions de dollars qui
normalement sont alloués à cette
transition par l'administration fédérale
à ce que cette agence qui doit les
débloquer contrôlé par une fidèle de
trump qui refusent de desserrer son
portefeuille
merci beaucoup richter la forteresse
assiégée de la maison blanche on gardera
cette expression merci à vous et à très
vite dans cette émission on va passer à
présent à notre décryptage en lien
direct justement avec l'expérience
électorale américaine doit-on se
préparer à voter par correspondance pour
les prochaines échéances régionales
notamment
c'est le thème de notre face à face au
but
[Musique]
face à face qui oppose ce soir jean noël
barrot bonsoir vous êtes députée du
modem des yvelines partisans de ce vote
par correspondance
vous avez même déposé une proposition de
loi en ce sens en juin dernier face à
vous constance le grip bonsoir reçoit
aussi d'être la députée les républicains
des hauts de seine un peu plus sceptique
voire plus sceptiques vraiment sur ce
vote par correspondance est dans la
position d'arbitrer ce soir bruno
cautrès derrière son écran via skype e
vous êtes le politologue au cevipof qui
nous rejoindra pas apparemment un petit
peu plus tard avant de vous donner la
parole à tous les deux
le vote par correspondance mode d'emploi
on voit cela avec maïté vraiment avec le
co vide le vote par correspondance a
pris une nouvelle dimension
ceux qui ont donné le ton les américains
ces dernières semaines pour leur
élection présidentielle on les a vu
défiler dans la rue
au total 65 millions d'entre eux ont
glissé leurs bulletins dans des boîtes
aux lettres
c'est deux fois plus qu'aux élections de
les etats-unis sont-ils les tout
premiers à casser les codes
institutionnels et bien non d'autres
pays ont adopté ce style pour éviter des
contaminations c'est le cas par exemple
de l'allemagne en bavière en mars
dernier on à voter aux municipales
exclusivement par correspondance
même constat en suisse dans le canton de
genève et pour tous
le résultat est le même ce mode de
scrutin séduit la preuve avec des taux
de participation beaucoup plus élevée
la france serait-elle donc à la traîne
détrompez-vous cette vidéo date de 1958
on y voit le très en vogue yves montand
en faire la promo dans les rues de paris
ont voté par correspondance vous devez
écrire à votre mère vous trouverez un
formulaire dans n'importe quelle mairie
vous pouvez aussi écrire sur papier
libre et surtout fournir la preuve que
vous êtes obligés de voter par
correspondance attestations fournies par
votre employeur
sauf que 17 ans plus tard en 1975 ce
mode de scrutin est supprimée en raison
des fraudes électorales notamment en
corse des fraudes qui sont aujourd'hui
le principal argument des détracteurs de
cette manière de voter alors jean noël
barrot le vote par correspondance
on l'a vu dans ce sujet ça n'est pas
nouveau mais finalement ce sont les
fraudes qui ont eu raison de lui en
offrant c'est ce qu'on est prêt
aujourd'hui à votre avis à réintroduire
sans risque ce vote par correspondance
je crois qu'en tout cas il faut se poser
la question est d'ailleurs les français
cela pose puisque on a aujourd'hui un
sondage qui vient d'être fait et qui
montrent que sept français sur dix sont
favorables à ce qu en tout cas le
chantier du vote à distance soit
réouvert sur la question de la fraude
coûté 65 millions d'américains ont voté
par correspondance
donald trump lui même a voté par
correspondance aux états unis et
aujourd'hui on a pas de cas de fraude
avérée
même chose en bavière où les élections
municipales se sont tenues le 29 mars
dernier sans qu'ils aient vraiment de
gros problèmes si la suisse si
l'allemagne savent le faire je dis pas
que c'est facile mais au moins on peut
se poser la question et dont il ya eu
quelques sujets et quelques problèmes
aux états unis on va reparler mais pour
vous et pour ensuite avoir le point de
vue contradictoires quels sont les
principaux avantages de ce vote par
correspondance
moi je crois tout simplement que dans un
contexte exceptionnel comme celui dans
lequel nous sommes ou le voter vous
expose à un risque de contamination
alors il faut qu'on puisse offrir des
alternatives pour ne pas mettre la
démocratie à l'arrêt et d'autre part
dans un jeu d'hier est dans une
situation un peu plus normale il ya
aussi des personnes qui du fait de leur
situation de leur handicap par exemple
de leur vulnérabilité pourrait trouver
dans le vote par correspondance
un moyen d'exprimer leurs opinions
d'exprimer leur choix sans avoir à se
déplacer dans d'autres instances le
gréement souvient du fiasco des
municipales où on a dû voter en pleine
crise sanitaire avec des reports
d'échéance au fond est-ce que c'est pas
le le vote le plus intelligent dans le
contexte mais au risque de vous décevoir
myriam en quoi je ne vais pas porter la
contradiction à jean-noël barrot et
m'opposer frontalement lui enverrai
placer ce sujet pour nous le dire les
bras j'ai plutôt envie que l'on n'écarte
pas d'un revers de main définitif voir
un peu dédaigneux l'idée d'introduire de
réintroduire en france le vote par
correspondance
j'ai bien écouté comme jean noël barrot
d'ailleurs la réponse à des ministres
l'intérieur gérald darmanin à
l'assemblée nationale avant-hier mémoire
et questions d'actualité qui
effectivement soro et les éléments
traditionnels et régulièrement mises en
avant par les ministères de l'intérieur
j'ai passé presque 2,5 en mai salle
intérieure dans le cabinet d'un ministre
de l'intérieur et je connais cette
position assez traditionnel je dirais
des ministères de l'interco sida
contraire rendre ce scrutin
incontestable aujourd'hui on peut
certainement travailler à voir comment
mettre des garde-fous des règles très
précises ne pas tomber dans les travers
et les erreurs et les fraudes entre
guillemets que le rire agricole d'haïti
en 1975 et faire les bonnes conclut
madame lave d'autres c'est ça on n'a pas
non plus la même
le contexte n'est certainement pas celui
de 1975 on a fait des progrès pour toute
une série de processus et de procédures
contre les fraudes en quelques mots
quelles peuvent-être j'imagine alors
peut-être que jean-noël barrot a
beaucoup plus ce travail et le sujet que
moi mais j'imagine que c'était
effectivement des gens qui venaient
enfin qu ils ont été plusieurs fois des
bidouillages depuis on ne peut pas
vérifier que la personne qui dit avoir
voté est bien celle là il ya deux
problèmes à mon avis a réglé le premier
c'est effectivement de bien s'assurer
que la personne qui glisse son bulletin
dans l'enveloppé qui l'enveloppent dans
l'enveloppé puis l'envol de l'envelope
puisqu'il ya trois enveloppes 1 pour le
vote par correspondance ikenoue mais
pour quand on vote par correspondance
on va mettre son bulletin dans
l'enveloppé com de com dans un bureau de
vote classique
on va avoir une deuxième enveloppe qui
est une enveloppe d'identification qui
va garantir que c'est bien vous qui
votez et une troisième qui va servir
pour pour le pour le pour la poste pour
la poste pour l'acheminement donc il ya
un premier problème au moment où la
personne glisse son bulletin dans
l'enveloppé
c'est un peu le même problème que l'on
rencontre pour les procurations faut
bien s'assurer que la volonté de
l'électeur est bien respectée et les
prod que vise donald trump sont un autre
type de fraude qui serait la
manipulation des bulletins mais ce
moment du dépouillement au moment du
dépouillement bien ces quelques aux
états unis pour bien comprendre c'est
que il ya des états qui ont considéré
que des bulletins qui arrivait après
jour de l'élection allait être décompté
d'autres états ne l'ont pas parce que ce
serait la législation jason qui s'est
surtout passé aux états unis et ce qui
créait beaucoup d'agitation et beaucoup
de tumulte c'est que donald trump a
perdu les élections et qui ne concède
pas sa défaite c'est ça qui crée de du
bazar si je puis dire
il ya effectivement plus de bulletins de
correspondre de vote par correspondance
que d'habitude il ya plus de
participation d'habitude entre 2016 et
2020 la participation aux élections
américaines a progressé de six points
entre les élections municipales en
france et la dernière édition elle s'est
effondré de 20 points
tous ne s'explique pas par le vote par
correspondance mais clairement le vote
par correspondance explique une partie
de ce résultat
ils ont peut-être aussi était un peu
surpris dans leur organisation par la
très forte participation par le sursaut
démocratique qu'on a vu aux états unis
reste qu'il peut y avoir des pressions à
la maison quand vous voilà mettez votre
enveloppe en famille de j'imagine
dans le salon familial alors que dans le
secret de l'isoloir êtes libre personne
ne vous regarde
non personne ne vous regarde mais les
pressions que vous dites d'ordre
familial si tant est qu'elle existe
vraiment et sur une échelle qui pourrait
être considérée comme significative
elles peuvent également s'exercer au
mans l'établissement des procurations
peut encore une fois il faut être plutôt
dans une attitude de confiance vis-à-vis
du comportement électoral la crise est
un mystère commence commandes con con
con qu'on aille en tout cas elle me
semble qui peut permettre de maintenir
voire de lutter contre l'effondrement de
la participation électorale doit être
regardée avec sérieux doit être analysée
étudier très très fier dans la majorité
vous êtes dans l'opposition il pourrait
y avoir un texte de loi
même si gérald darmanin ministre les
élections n'est pas favorable
vous pourriez faire bouger des lignes ce
qui est sûr c'est que il faut que ce
soit un travail collectif parce qu'il ya
un sujet législatif
il faut que la loi évolue mais il ya
évidemment un sujet technique qui ne
pourra être résolue que si le ministère
de l'intérieur décide d'ouvrir le
chantier est associée évidemment la
poste et les acteurs de la chaîne de
ceux de ce vote à distance donc c'est
pas quelque chose qu'on peut décréter à
l'assemblée nationale coûte cher à
l'état
ça c'est pas totalement évident parce
que les opérations de vote sont très
coûteuses il ya d'ailleurs dans nos
modalités électorales
aujourd'hui des coûts très significative
qui mériterait d'être réexaminés je
parle pas simplement du vote en lui même
et y compris dans l'acheminement
si on décide d'ouvrir ce chantier on le
fait pour quand vous savez comme moi que
jean louis debré va rendre son rapport
sur le calendrier des régionales et
départementales qui vraisemblablement
crise sanitaire oblige sera reporté
elles seront reporter ces élections il
faut le faire tout de suite le vote par
correspondance dès les prochaines
échéances
en tout cas moi je trouve comme je dis
que l'idée d'étudier la puissiez passer
au vote par correspondance est une idée
intéressante qu'il faut ouvrir le
travail de réflexion tout de suite pour
éventuellement avoir eu le temps de
passer en revue tout
les hypothèses avoir étudié tous les
tenants et aboutissants et vu exactement
quelle était juridiquement
législativement techniquement
administrativement les différents verrou
à faire sauter pour être éventuellement
effectivement si on arrive à mener ce
travail à bien et qu on le commence dès
demain matin
mettre en place ce vote par
correspondance pour les échéances
prochaines qui sont des échéances très
importantes
je voudrais pas qu'on considère que les
élections départementales et régionales
c'est juste la sphère des partis est
donc prévue pour mars prochain mais qui
pourrait avoir lieu en juin voilà où ils
vont être décalés nous espérons nous les
républicains qu'elles ne seront pas
décaler plus tard que joint ça c'est un
point sur lequel nous insistons beaucoup
mais ce sont des échéances électorales
important beaucoup de choses sont
décidées et mises en place par nos
collectivités territoriales la région et
département donc il est important qu'il
y ait une participation électorale de
bonne tenue est clairement nous ne
souhaitons pas revivre ce que nous avons
vécu pour et le premier tour et le
second tour des élections municipales
oui je suis d'accord avec constance le
grip c'est d'ailleurs ce que nous avions
dit au mois de juin quand avec les
députés du groupe modem nous avons
déposé une proposition de loi dont
l'esprit a été repris au sénat par le
groupe des républicains et le groupe du
parti socialiste qui ont eux aussi
déposé des amendements en ce sens que
nous avons 10 et essayons de nous
préparer pour les municipales mais si
nous ne sommes pas prêts pour les
municipales au moins nous aurons fait le
travail de manière à ce que si des
scrutins ultérieure devait se tenir au
beau milieu d'une crise sanitaire nous
soyons prêts à ce que les opérations
électorales puissent se tenir
et vous pensez peut-être avoir l'oreille
de l'exécutif là dessus ou pas parce
qu'on a l'impression qu'on a écouté on
lire ni régionale des as sont reportés
en juin on lire dans le rapport de du
président et aimerait plus près c'est un
sujet dont il peut s'en passer je pense
qu'il est possible qu' il y ait dans ce
rapport une incitation à ce que nous
puissions avoir ce travail ouvrir ce
travail
oui comme tous les responsables de deux
mouvements politiques pour prendre la
température et comprendre les arguments
je lui ai fait part
de cette proposition que nous faisons
que françois bayrou défend depuis
longtemps du vote à distance et je
souhaite vivement la retrouver dans son
rapport mais sous la forme d'une
invitation à ce qu'un travail collectif
puis se trouve alors on verra ce que ça
donnera avec ce rapport en tout cas on
entend votre appel
il est en crise sanitaire oblige de
s'adapter et de voter pourquoi pas par
la poste par correspondance rester avec
nous parce que le vote à distance
figurez vous est même envisagée par les
députés que vous êtes mais dans votre
travail de législateur s'est tout de
suite ma journée à l'assemblée avec
thomas des prêts la crise sanitaire qui
pourrait avoir raison du vote en
présentiel comme on dit dans l'hémicycle
n'est ce pas thomas où exactement même
que se passerait-il demain pour
l'assemblée nationale en période de
grave crise comme celle qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui c'est la question que se
sont posée plusieurs députés je vous
raconte alors depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire des députés de tous les
groupes parlementaires se penchent sur
cette question comment faire fonctionner
à l'assemblée nationale en période de
crise en période de crise sanitaire mais
pas que s'il y avait également un
incendie dans l'hémicycle une crue de la
seine ou encore eu des manifestants qui
empêcherait les députés de rentrer dans
le palais bourbon
comment faire pour continuer de
travailler malgré ces conditions les
députés dans leurs rapports ont fait une
proposition parmi d'autres celle
d'introduire un vote par correspondance
en vote électronique lors des séances de
l'assemblée nationale alors comment ça
se passerait on a posé la question aux
députés qui remet ce rapport le député
modem sylvain vazey herman le vote
numérique ou le l'utilisation des outils
numériques en cas de vote pourrait
s'appliquer de façon solennelle sur un
ensemble de textes pour que l'ensemble
des députés qu'ils ne puissent pas
physiquement se rendre dans l'hémicycle
puisse tout de même exercer leurs
responsabilités fondamentales de vote et
puisse donc se positionner sur les
textes on va pas voter entre une pizza à
une émission de télé on va voter dans
des conditions solennel à une précis sur
l'ensemble d'un texte dès lors que les
députés seraient massivement empêcher et
que le fonctionnement de l'assemblée
serait massivement en empêcher parmi les
autres points on peut également lire que
l'assemblée pourrait siéger en dehors
des murs on pourrait aller où
il a semblé ne se faisait pas ici au
palais bourbon évidemment en tant qu'élu
de strasbourg j'ai mon coeur penche pour
le parlement européen qui est tout à
fait adapté à ça il y en a plusieurs à
l'étude un des des grandes salles comme
le palais des congrès peuvent être pas
mais adapter la salle de versailles 1
n'est pas la plus adaptée la salle la
salle du congrès qu'on utilise qui est
parfaite pour une journée ou une après
midi mais pas du tout pour un travail
parlementaire au fil de l'eau avec les
amendements avec les prises de parole
avec les micros et avec avec l'ensemble
des des éléments de travail qui
constitue notre vie de tous les jours
deux députés alors les propositions de
ce rapport font l'unanimité parmi tous
les groupes du parlement oui mais voilà
il reste un point d'interrogation quand
décidé de passer à l'assemblée nationale
en mode crise et surtout qui décide
pour le moment c'est la conférence des
présidents qui le décident à la majorité
mais voilà les groupes d'opposition
aimerait avoir plus de place dans cette
décision certains voudraient qu'on
prenne la décision de passer l'assemblée
nationale en mode crise à l'unanimité
alors qu'on pense les députés on leur a
posé la question si demain il y avait
une autre majorité plus incertaine plus
directive
on pourrait très bien se retrouver avec
une conférence des présidents qui impose
et le tempo de l'état d'urgence et le
tempo d'un fonctionnement en temps de
crise de l'assembler qui n'est pas le
fonctionnement normal nous pensions que
les conditions de la décision devait
prévoir que un seul président de groupe
pouvait s'opposer au déclenchement pour
éviter tout risque d'abus on l'a vu lors
de la première crise en mars
l'image imaginer qu'il faudrait qu'on
ait besoin de l'unanimité on pourrait
bloquer l'institution directement donc
ce n'est pas souhaitable
je crois que c'était plus ce matin un
petit peu d'exercice de posture c'est
parce que j'ai entendu pendant les
travaux
voilà même et avant que ce rapport entre
en application il faudra d'abord qu'il
soit voté par les députés la semaine
prochaine dans cette fameuse conférence
des présidents et que les députés
débattent dans l'hémicycle de cette
fameuse question du vote électronique
dans les prochaines semaines alors ce
sont des votes à distance 1 il s'agit
pas d'envoyer une enveloppe
je pense que c'est pratique et d'un
sombre deux pays
à titre exceptionnel au parlement
européen en ce moment pour que le
travail des parlementaires au père
puisse continuer à se dérouler à peu
près correctement jeu favorable à ce que
les choses soient extradés vers man
encadré décidé d'une manière très
concertée que ce soit à titre
exceptionnel ne s'agit pas de se
transformer en députés qui passeraient
longtemps appuyer sur les boutons mais
encore une fois je crois qu'il ne faut
rien écarter par principe et être dans
le cadre de ces résistances ex effet
inverse bien fonctionner notre
institution parlementaire démocratique
c'est essentiel de pouvoir envisager
avec pragmatisme et réalisme
toutes les options et vous jean noël
barrot alors que certains députés
s'inquiètent d'ailleurs de siéger encore
aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle parfois
trop de trop nombreux est ce que c'est
une solution
écoutez moi je considère que évidemment
rien ne peut remplacer la qualité d'un
débat en personne dans l'hémicycle de
l'assemblée nationale
cela produit de très bonnes choses et il
faut le conserver mais néanmoins il est
absolument indispensable qu'à tout
moment la démocratie puisse continuer et
donc il faut que nous puissions si des
circonstances comme ceux numérisés les
parlementaires que nous puissions atout
non non pas la numériser mais la nature
et la résilience à tout moment merci
infiniment d'être placé sur le plateau
d'el cpc la fin de cette émission se
retrouve évidemment ans demain pour un
nouveau ça vous regarde tout de suite
votre soirée documentaire avec jean
pierre gratien ab
[Musique]